maman a tort s'appelle toujours
d'ailleurs puisque c'est le tube le
premier oui mylène c'est difficile de
faire un tube parce qu'après quand on
veut faire une deuxième chanson c'est
pas ça non ce n'est simple pour personne
c'est vrai parce que la grande phrase si
on vous attend au tournant ouais alors
qu'on fait en sorte d'avoir une chanson
aussi forte que la première
et puis d'avoir des prestations aussi
bonne que les premiers simples non c'est
pas simple parce que le public est dur
et exigeant et le métier aussi
donc c'est comme ça que se fait le tri
au fur et à mesure et puis un à qui
restent et puis d'autres qui partiront
il y en a d'autres qui reviendront et
puis tu as envie de faire une carrière
militaire meurt ouais je crois que c'est
le rêve d'être personnes qui débutent
respect je m'y accroche on est de faire
une carrière c'est à dire mais ça
s'apprend comme ça aussi c'est ça un
métier la chanson donc falloir prendre
des cours de danse des corps plein de
choses pour pouvoir éventuellement faire
de la scène ah ah bon tu as envie de
danser
en plus ce sont bien ces suffit pas de
chanter on peut faire du théâtre oui je
peux faire cinéma j'espère le cinéma
mais ça je vais attendre un peu pour
l'instant je mets ce que c'est parce que
tu as 23 ans est tout jeune et que tu te
dis que finalement tu as envie de tout
faire un métier quand on veut tout faire
c'est ce que disait un certain nombre de
gens tapent eu peur pour se dispersent
non justement c'est ce dont je parlais
je préfère pour l'instant me consacrer à
la chanson et plus tard le cinéma s'il
fait appel à moi je viendrai quel effet
ça fait d'être très connu à 23 ans c'est
sympa c'est difficile à vivre pour
l'instant ça mais pas trop pénible c'est
même plutôt agréable
je ne sais pas avec peut-être cinq ans
de recul je m'en plaindrais peut-être
mais là ça va tu as peut parler hein
en tout cas toi tu as beaucoup chanté on
a vu beaucoup d les radios med a peu
parlé parce que je disais c'est que dans
les émissions qu'ils sont
consacré aux variétés la plupart du
temps les interviews passe un peu ouvre
et puis on a tendance à interviewer
quelqu'un qui est installé depuis cinq
dix ans dans le métier plutôt qu'une
gêne personne et puis les questions sont
pas tres moins intéressante non plus
mais c'est pas facile ça va aussi de
dire beau la technique ça va pas les
questions ça va pas de toujours de
toujours voir comment dire tendance à
donner les torts aux autres et parfois
c'est un peu comme maman a tort
finalement c'est pas toi 14,1 à nouveau
tous les jours les autres quand l'état
facile non
c'est bien oui c'est vrai c'est très
important
non non non non je moi je reconnais tous
mes torts ouais mais c'est vrai que
j'aime bien accuser les gens aussi mais
quand j'en ai la conviction je vais le
bitume apparaît pas une fille facile
comme on dit il faut quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de caractère
bah oui j'ai du caractère une fille
facile ça je ne sais pas d'accord où
êtes-vous la salle où fort que leur
l'aspect sauvage poser la question vient
va découvrir maintenant un groupe que
vous avez pu découvrir dans un précédent
king cher ils s'appellent les bandits
c'est encore une chanteuse puisque
aujourd'hui oui exceptionnellement que
des chanteurs
le titre de la chanson a ouai c'est
vraiment comme ça ça s'appelle toutes
les nuits à tout